I'm a boy
one cautious optimist
so the answer to your question is I am
optimistic I'm optimistic about how
we're going to be able to handle the
diseases that we have now namely HIV and
the global health issues of the
developing world and I'm optimistic that
we're going to be able to be prepared
enough for new challenges that come
along because there it's a perpetual
challenge the possibility of emerging
and re-emerging new infections and I'm
also optimistic that we will see our way
to getting the people of this country at
least to be covered so that they don't
have to worry about health and getting
sick and not having the wherewithal to
be taken care of
well the the the the most pressing
ethical questions is to make sure that
everything you do from a scientific
standpoint is done for the ultimate good
and positive issue for for the for the
for the people that you're caring about
the idea of a discovery for some
self-aggrandizing reason that could have
a potential negative impact it by its
very nature needs to be struck down so
we need to be guided by firm ethical
principles in what we do in every area
of life not just in medicine and health
but in health and medicine and science
it's even more imperative because you
unleash the forces of science and if you
don't have an ethical handle on what
you're doing the potential damage can be
enormous